bello tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video un gioco rischia ma chi le
tue fire hanno fatto un gioco su steam
t'altro anche frighi e dell'italiano
attenzione incredibile sta cosa dove
l'obiettivo principale del gioco è
bruciare gli insetti ok ho anche ragni
perché effettivamente ci sono i ragni ma
primo contatto va bene sono per la
finestra non possono proprio ispezione
ha veramente fatto bene
scusa sembra fatto benissimo che schifo
ok per uccidere con uscite non può
succedere lo non lo può succedere ha
dato di sotto che perfetto apre una
porta prendi porta blocco schiacciare
comporta blocco primo santucci eccolo
perfetto primo sangue uccidi un ragno
vabbè che schifo che schifo a posto
aiuto che schifo come fanno esserci 2000
ragni casa qual è il problema
praticamente in base alle uccisioni
posto solo carne porte
localizzatore di ragni va bene e va beh
il televisore mischia ci prova ancora
potenza di fuoco presi dal accada va dal
bagno dove il bagno questo il problema è
che non fosse uscita posso uscire con
dieci anni uccisi va bene
poi c'è uno sportello oddio è cascata la
tv che schifo vedo ragnetti che se ne
vanno in giro madonna è orribile
non lo so ragazzi aiuto che schifo a
posto ragazzi c'è una cosa qua un regalo
equipaggi impotenza frullato proteico
presidenti scoperta più principale
bisogna andare nel menu principale per
smontare quello va bene comunque per
adesso ho trovato solo un paio di ragni
idriche lanciagli libro addosso quale
libro è un televisore ciò che è bello
sto tizio ma che mi rappresenta
posso uscire
che schifo lo schiavo dio è vivo e vivo
dov'è dov'è andato di là dov'è andato
sto pezzente s'è messo nel cassetto non
sono io dove eccolo maledetto schifoso
l'aido adesso una lampada ancora prezzo
possa aprire a portare il bagno per
favore 4 uccisione proprie malefatte già
quattro forse perché le usi proprio gel
e sprechi quindi poi devi di farle anche
strani supersonici cela corrono come se
è impossibile a dio sarà sul muro fa
schifo sto gioco ragazzi che li mette
proprio fermi ma no no no ma orribile
non aiutatemi lanciafiamme vi prego
orribile perché te li mette proprio in
un punto fermo da proprio la sensazione
pochi sono veri come il problema larga
da bagno eccola
ecco ragno domanda eccola è uscito è
uscito è uscito ci sono ragni nel bagno
ci sono ora ho poche munizioni raga sono
quasi ho finito le munizioni
ho dato fuoco alla casa madonna ho
mandato tutto portato tutto a folco usa
sta roba
e lo spazzolone del cesso che schifo
basta a casa fa vomitare ragazzi siano
affidatemi
giocato una pistola la rivoltella rapida
ragazzi lascia parole il gioco dell'anno
vi prego fatemi uscire un ragno ne ho
bisogno ne ho bisogno sempre sognato di
fare io quando vedo un ragno un insetto
strano io sogno di poter di sparare
ragazze il mio sogno perché non è morto
veramente rimasto attaccato da quanto si
è perso
ecco che schifo è impossibile per carlo
reja impossibile adesso sarà sul muro da
qualche parte se mettete radio che sono
non lo vedo più draga è sparito e da
qualche parte ma non lo vedo mannaggia
al vicolo 36
so che sei qui schifoso parassita eccoti
è morto l'ho ucciso perfetta giocata del
secolo ha posto a posto ma si può uscire
attenzione si può uscire
credo che in giardino troverò la prezzo
chiesto rumore a noto che mi ha fatto
uscire i suoi completata ma vieni tutto
l'equipaggiamento quando giocherà una
visione meno male perché avevo sbloccato
una pistola un sacco di ross primo
contatto bello ragni eliminati 12
obiettivi quattro su cinque 21 quasi
fatto tutto c'è il lanciafiamme
effettivamente chelab l'arma finale
ovviamente gioca incontri ravvicinati o
ragazzi per essere una demo è piena di
roma è questa gioca vediamo la parte
perché i moventi e finale
per ora e le robe bene occhio c'è un
ragno fianco c'era un ragno bianco non
ho capito perché era bianco però va bene
ma poi bello è che si staccano solo dal
momento in cui lancio le robe al momento
in cui l'eroe arrivano a terra perché
quando le lancio addio si stacca dopo
eccolo il bastone civette tempo
madonna mia ragazzi veramente spaghetti
western ragazzi mi hai messo un colpo
solo
ecco perfetto ottimo utilizzo
dell'ultimo colpo che avevo polo
shuriken però non ho ancora usato
ragazzino shuriken per fare fuori i
ragni piatta non è nulla raga che schifo
no ma dai ma dai ragazzi ma vi posso
riprendere gli studi che non lo sapevo
che schifo dio
no ragazzi ho rivisto perfetto non so
dove sia andato a finire l'altro però
s'è ficcato dentro un altro voglia
ucciso è rimasto un'ora gatteschi è
scappato ma non so dove quel problema
mannaggia il vicolo questo è aperto
eccolo lì ok
direi che ci sia madonna che schifo mi
sento roba addosso e ski fissi mostro
gioco ma è la mente malata che si è
inventata la roba vi prego ditemelo
ne ho bisogno no perché la riprodotto
alla perfezione quello il fatto di bper
di spavento sta roba
ok è tanta roba ma non vedo nessuno
ragazzi normale forse le piante no
che schifo cos'è quello addio esplodi io
che no no no no no no no no va beh
questa è la roba più orribile la pista
non ho colto
no ragazzi e ragazze di più mi rifiuto
di rifiuto che poi è bello che se scappa
con ritrovarli un casino
ore 9 ghazi questa fucka gato dei no non
mi sento è orribile
non voglio più giocare sta roba mi sento
veramente che sto giocando un gioco che
non fa non è mio ma per me non fa
veramente per un gioco il mondo questo
il mondo eccolo mannaggia è dato fuoco a
posto a porta cosa tranquillo ci ha già
pensato io non ho idea eccola eccola qua
ecco la prova a scappare adesso è prova
sia fatta la zona non uscite l'acqua
tanto tranquilli pronuciate i suoi la
vostra stirpe schifosa
mannaggia chi va inventato guarda ti sei
inventato i ragni quel giorno veramente
cosa fare altro qualsiasi altra
che schifo fossero in un mondo ci sono i
ragni che schifo no ragazzi ne vado via
via via via da questa creatura di bile
via via via via via via via è orribile
un gioco orribile
voglio uscire fatemi uscire ragazzi per
me possiamo concludere questo episodio
molto profondo è bello faremo il
prossimo la prossima volta sono curioso
di vedere che cosa mi caga fuori sta
roba che adesso vado in giro con le
pinze mica go in mano comunque è vero
che video vi sia piaciuto come se i
ragazzi lasciano un momento è un mi
piace anche ai vari social che come
notizia le centrali si discute e non ci
vediamo alle professioni della ragazza
[Musica]